[Musique]
dimanche 1er janvier 2017
il est 15 heures 28 le ciel est bleu il
fait 8 degrés c'est parfait pour aller
faire votre bécane
là
[Musique]
oh
8° ça va on a connu pire pour débuter
l'année bon par contre pour faire un
tour de bécanes ça va ça fonctionne par
contre ça glisse un peu va falloir faire
attention en chaque début d'année à
cette période tout le monde prend de
bonnes résolutions
certains veulent faire du poids certains
veulent faire du sport personnellement
je suis persuadé que ça ne sert
strictement à rien ces bonnes
résolutions ce que de toute façon on s'y
tient trois jours et après c'est terminé
les mauvaises habitudes reviennent très
très vite
du coup je vais juste tenir la bonne
résolution j'ai commencé l'année
dernière c'est-à-dire un blog par jour
et toi de ton côté
c'est quoi tes bonnes résolutions
là c'est terminé je l'est
5 gaye sarr à ce même si on commence une
nouvelle année on a encore deux jeux
concours
le premier c'est pour gagner le parfum
diesel bad n'oubliez pas dès qu'on
arrive aux 500 abonnés il est pour vous
je vous renvoie la vidéo qui explique
comment le gagner vous avez le lien en
haut de l'écran et le deuxième lot c'est
la tondeuse à barbe val je vous renvoie
également la vidéo vous avez le lien qui
est là haut pour voir exactement comment
la gagner alors entre une tondeuse et un
parfum vous avez de quoi faire faire
régulièrement des jeux concours pour
vous remercier de votre fidélité vous
remercier d'être présents et de regarder
le blog
dites moi ce qui vous ferait plaisir
comme cadeau des choses qui sont
réalisables me demandez pas une bagnole
à voyage à l'île maurice des choses
comme ça ça sera avec grand plaisir mais
j'ai peur de ne pas pouvoir le financer
donc dites moi ce qui vous ferait
plaisir les choses que vous n auriez
gagné et dans la mesure du possible je
ferai mon maximum pour vous les offrir
en attendant je vous renvoie au concours
garder sa bonne chance et merci de votre
participation
oh
[Musique]